You syllables answer,
it would be nine 11.
I was working at the Wall Street Journal
at the time.
My main job was as an editor in the days
and weeks and months after nine 11,
I spent all my time,
uh,
editing stories for the Journal's front
page about the fallout from nine 11,
most of it international,
uh,
at least initially.
And I edited many stories about Islam
and about Muslims and about the turmoil
that has enveloped,
uh,
that religion and its adherence.
Uh,
almost all of that had to do with Islam
overseas and Muslims,
uh,
outside the boundaries of the United
States.
I genuinely just began to get curious
over time about Muslims in this country
and the journal was chased from its
offices by nine 11.
The,
uh,
the attacks took place literally across
the street from the journal offices and
for a year we were dispersed in
different places when the newspaper
recollected itself and its old office.
As in my work life became a little bit
more normal again.
Um,
I decided to carve out some time to work
on a series of articles about Muslims in
this country.
And increasingly as I did those
articles,
I realized that one,
the American Muslim experience was an
entirely distinct from Muslim immigrant
experiences elsewhere and even more
distinct from the experience of Muslims
in the predominantly Muslim world.
And as I got deeper and deeper into that
and found the tremendous variety within
American Islam and found the tremendous
flux that exists within that subject
area,
that there is no one American Islam,
there is no one model of American Muslim
and that Muslims themselves in this
country in a way that is mostly very
healthy and very encouraging.
When you come to understand it,
are engaged in a,
in an extraordinary debate over what it
means to be a Muslim in a wealthy
Western society,
particularly the united that of the
United States,
that that began to have the feel of
enough of a having enough heft to be
worthy,
not just of newspaper articles,
but maybe have a book.
And the struggle that the,
uh,
that you mentioned that I used as the
subtitle for the book that struggle is
the internal struggle within Islam in
this country.
Much of what I write about in the book
has to do with conflicts among Muslims
in this country from many different
backgrounds,
with many different understandings of
their own religion as they try to sort
out what it means to be Muslim.